maybe you can speak to the
this dance of uh
netscape versus internet explorer you've
uh
you've thrown some loving words towards
microsoft throughout this conversation
but that's the theme with the
i mean steve jobs had a similar sort of
commentary
from a big sort of philosophical
principle perspective
can you comment on like the approach
that microsoft has taken with internet
explorer
from ie1 to edge today is there
something that you see as valuable that
they're doing
in the in the occasional copying and
that this kind of stuff or
is it um is the world worse off because
internet explorer exists
so i'm going to segment this into
historical errors because i think
microsoft is today with
quite a different company and what
they're doing with edge is different but
back then
um gates you know aggressive character
not really original in my view
not an originator steve jobs famously
said once he doesn't have any taste and
i don't mean this in a small way there's
no taste
you can see this apple at the time had
beautiful typography and
ligatures and kerning and the fonts
looked great and
windows had this sort of ugly system
font that was carefully aligned with
pixels so it
didn't get anything what is it i'm sorry
to keep interrupting well why did why
was internet explorer winning
throughout the history of these
competitions distribution distribution
matters more than anything and this is
why
um you know even now we're seeing in the
browser wars edge
doing better because it's being foisted
on people of windows we have windows 10
boxes at home
we have some windows 7 boxes we or
laptops we keep running too because we
we don't connect with the internet
generally but um
but but uh once you have that operating
system
you can you can force you know edge and
and apple did it with safari too
it's not unique to microsoft that's sad
but
distribution matters and that's why uh i
think ie was going to win and that's why
everybody at netscape felt were doomed
this was something michael toy and jamie
would say we're doomed
um but for a while there we had a chance
and we innovated in netscape too we
did a big platform push java and
javascript and
plugins more plugins and
you know more html table features and
and really started making a printable
stack out of what were pretty static web
languages and even
in the beta releases netscape 2 people
were using javascript to build what you
would call single page applications like
gmail
and they were using javascript locally
to compute things and to call the server
on a hidden frame in the background
so it was prefiguring a lot of what came
later as ajax
or dynamic javascript dynamic html
you